so could you explain to us what is
actually happening in Hong Kong okay so
these protests started back in I believe
end of May or early June when a
extradition bill was proposed and the
extradition bill was a lot of people in
Hong Kong saw that as a veiled attempt
to be able to extradite people from Hong
Kong to mainland China and just with
with people feeling like China's been
encroaching on the rights of Hong
Kongers it sort of broke the camel's
back that was sort of the final straw
for a lot of people and so they started
protesting and it's funny because what
could have been put to rest very easily
they ended up withdrawing the bill
formally anyway not too long ago but if
they had done that months ago this
wouldn't have spiraled into what it is
now now they have five demands there's
been incredibly harsh police brutality
there's been basically every single week
there's been protests and they've had up
to up to half a million people marching
in the streets in pouring rain in
extremely hot weather and it's just
incredible determination on the part of
these protesters incredible organization
and it's funny because you're starting
to see other movements take tactics from
the Hong Kong protesters because of how
effective they've been in just staying
unified and staying on message I've
never covered anything like it it's
extremely well-organized and it's not
the kind of solidarity or unification
you see in a lot of movements a lot of
people will try to co-opt it and push
their own messages but they have their
five demands now and the job would so
they want full withdrawal of the
extradition bill which finally just
recently happened they want dual
universal suffrage for the Legislative
Council and I think one of the other I
can't remember what the other government
body is but they want to be able to
choose their own leaders rather than
having the Chinese Communist Party
choose who they can elect from they want
they want the classification of the
rioters to be dropped because basically
in order to protest in Hong Kong
you have to you have to apply for a
letter of no objection and if you get
that letter of no objection then you can
protest but what they dried tried to do
to stop the protest was now not issue
any of the letters no objection so if
they don't then they get charge of
writing the riot right charge can put
you in prison for up to ten years so
they want the classification of writing
of riots to be dropped they want amnesty
for the arrested protesters how many is
that
I think that's oh and the last one is
they want an independent investigation
into the police for the conduct that
they've been using they've been using
expired to your guests they've been
using excessive force
they've been firing tear gas and
enclosed spaces which is extremely
dangerous
they've been targeting journalists when
they enacted the anti mask law the idea
was that you're not allowed to be
wearing a mask when you're protesting
but they have made they were supposed to
make exceptions for people who need
masks for work which would be
journalists however they were still
abusing that and they were even people
who weren't protesting they would arrest
them for wearing masks or they would
intimidate them they told journalists
that they couldn't wear masks and
threatened to rip them off and yeah it's
just really no no accountability on the
on behalf of the police and basically
the government has been running defense
for them and trying to justify all of
the tactics they've been using and it's
it's just it's it's kind of gone out of
control the public in Hong Kong has sort
of turned against like one of the main
things social movement needs is public
support and one of the the best ways to
squash a movement is to turn the public
against them it's extremely hard for
them to do that when the police are also
harassing intimidating and brutalizing
regular citizens not just protesters so
even if they do try to put undercover
police into the protests and have them
either beat people up throw Molotov
cocktails or cause general chaos
the overwhelming majority of the public
support is still with the Hong Kong
protesters like there was one instance
there they were trying to kettle the
protesters and basically instead of
because they couldn't run away
they were basically were basically
cornered and a bunch of residents opened
their doors to let them into the
building and hide them you don't really
see that and any other protest anywhere
else it's really incredible
[Music]